[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission où
on parle alimentation agriculture
écologique et aussi politique et nous
recevons cette semaine Jean-René
Cazeneuve bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et avec moi
pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour Merci vous êtes
député du Gers depuis 2017 député
Renaissance rapporte général du budget
mais ingénieur de formation vous avez
été directeur général d'Apple directeur
général adjoint de Bouygues Telecom vous
avez aussi travaillé chez Saint-Gobain
compacte et Cisco c'est en 2014 que vous
vous piquez de politique vous devenez
conseiller municipal d'Auch dans le Gers
vous connaissez une ascension au
fulgurante aux côtés d'Emmanuel Macron
vous portez ses combats tels d'Artagnan
pour Louis XII dont vous arborez le look
en hommage au héros gascon et la
macronie peut compter sur les trois
mousquetaires de la famille Cazeneuve
votre fils est également dép et votre
fille ancienne conseillère du chef de
l'État et comme ils étaient quatre et
bien votre gendre est directeur de
cabinet d'Elizabeth borne à Matignon et
en bon mousquetaire vous êtes donc aussi
fidèle au chef de l'État qu'à votre
terre le Gers où vous nous emmenez pour
ce déjeuner oui Brigitte 100% sud-ouest
avec du Maghreb canard accompagné
d'asperges vertes et en dessert une
croustade aux pommes dans le dessous des
plats du foie gras sans gavage c'est
possible mais est-ce vraiment du foie
gras reportage dans cette émission dans
les pieds dans le plats l'inflation qui
bouleverse les courses des Français dans
le caddie moins de viande et davantage
de marques de distributeurs détails à
suivre
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
genre des Cazeneuve quelle charge
mentale cette émission lorsqu'on est
député du Gers le département ou le
canard et le King le roi pas question
pour vous d'exiger du saumon des
escargots ou encore une bavette de bœuf
le retour en circonscription serait un
peu compliqué non toute une filière qui
en plus est décimée par la grippe
aviaire compte sur vous pour la défendre
et la promouvoir je le vois dans vos
yeux de d'Artagnan vous auriez tellement
aimé nous demander du foie gras le totem
du terroir du Gers mais là attention le
en même temps du patron est passé par là
oui au canard mais en même temps pas
question de dépenser trop en cette
période rude pour le pouvoir d'achat et
aussi pas question d'aller sur le
terrain du bien-être animal question
urticante donc banco pour notre canard
mais 100 fois gras voilà Brigitte
comment on se retrouve avec du magret
une pièce dont on pourrait croire
qu'elle est vieille comme l'animal mais
pas du tout elle a été inventée par un
gerçoit naturellement le chef André
Daguin qui créa dans les années 60 cette
nouvelle manière de préparer filet alors
dites moi Jean-René Cazeneuve vous ne
concevez pas un seul repas sans se
sacro-saint canard j'ai la chance d'être
vous l'avez dit originaire d'un
territoire béni des dieux en matière
culinaire donc je vais pas vous citer
tous les produits effectivement le
canard est assez emblématique il y a son
confit on mange sous forme de confit
évidemment il y a tout est bon dans le
canard vous avez les gésiers vous avez
le foie gras le magret on y reviendra
mais il y a aussi le port noir gascon
aussi la poule noire de la poule noire
d'astarack oui voilà on a vraiment les
vins on en parlera j'espère aussi voilà
j'ai la chance d'être le représentant
d'un territoire avec de très nombreux
agriculteurs c'est un des départements
les plus agricoles de France avec des
produits magiques comme le comme le
canard peut-être sur André Daguin qui a
inventé avant André Daguin qui a été le
chef emblématique de l'Hôtel de France à
Auch à tel point que bon maintenant il
est décédé depuis quelques années mais
20 ans après on me disait oh mais oui
mais c'est là que qui s'appelle André
Daguin il avait fermé depuis 20 ans il
avait cédé mais on parlait encore de lui
c'est international oui oui ça a été un
grand ambassadeur avec sa sagouaille ça
facon enfin là c'est le Gascon par
excellent on ne connaissait pas le
magret on connaissait le canard
évidemment mais on le mangeait pas comme
ça c'est à dire que on ne mangeait pas
comme une comme une pièce de viande
rouge on le on l'avait en confit on
l'avait en bocal mais on l'avait fait
mais pas alors le magret c'est la c'est
la poitrine du noix c'est ça ou d'un
canard
c'est ce morceau là du canard absolument
et donc on le
mangeait pas comme un comme un steak en
fait
cette manière de manger le cap 59 ou 60
c'est ça alors on va le goûter ce magret
alors
c'est pas le magret que vous aviez
l'habitude de voir en tout cas parce que
généralement il y a une couche de
graisse un peu épaisse sur le magret non
oui alors il y a plusieurs manières de
le cuisiner bien évidemment ce serait
trop simple alors André Daguin lui le
prenait la pièce
la pièce du magret enlever le enlever le
gras faisait revenir saisir le magret
mais évidemment on ne perd pas le gras
parce que ça dépend parce que
franchement je vous expliquerai
et il faisait revenir le grain à côté
pour évidemment donner donner du goût et
l'ajouter à part tout de suite que le
gras c'est bon moi j'appartiens
évidemment un territoire ou le gras
c'est bon et aujourd'hui beaucoup je
garde la peau et on le fait
effectivement revenir
croustillante et puis
retournez rapidement et puis vous le
mangez saignant comme ça allez goûter le
vous allez nous dire ce que vous en
pensez si il vient directement de votre
terroir ou pas celui-là alors justement
non j'ai eu les précisions parce que
Monsieur monsieur gazeneuve avait
demandé un Maghreb du Gers il se trouve
que chez Françoise qui prépare nos
petits plats à trouver qu'un magret des
Landes donc un magret concurrent mais il
a une IGP mais je sais pas quelle est la
différence si comme ça vous pouvez nous
dire s'il vient du Gers ou des Landes
moi je suis pas capable et alors pour
l'instant là tu as trois astuces voilà
pour bien parce qu'on a déjà un peu on
en a déjà un petit peu parlé alors pour
bien cuire à magret il est impératif de
quadriller justement cette couche de
gras de le quadriller parce que ça va
permettre effectivement à la chaleur
d'aller chauffer non pas chauffer aussi
la chair et simplement c'est plus joli
une fois que on le sait mais c'est
surtout l'assurance que la viande cuise
bien à l'intérieur de sa chair il faut
bien assaisonner ce magret avant la
cuisson avec du gros sel et du poivre
mignonette en les faisant bien pénétrer
peut-être avec les doigts dans cette
chaire enfin pour une cuisson à la poêle
puisque monsieur Cazeneuve l'a dit il y
a plein de façons de le cuire mais pour
une cuisson à la poêle c'est d'abord
dans une poêle bien chaude côté graisse
et la graisse on peut effectivement
l'évacuer et ensuite on remet un petit
côté une minute 8 minutes sur le côté
graisse une minute sur le côté chair et
ensuite on le laisse un petit peu
reposer parce que il va un tout petit
peu saigner il faut attendre 5 minutes
avant de le découper et de le servir
vous validez absolument voilà très bien
vous le faites vous vous le préparez à
la maison vous aimez cuisiner
le magret c'est assez simple oui en
cuisine quand on a de bons produits en
habitude d'ailleurs quand on a un bon
produit c'est pas la peine d'être très
sophistiqué je dis pas que la cuisine
Gascogne n'est pas sophistiquée mais on
a la chance d'avoir de formidable
produit peut-être vous dire sur le
canard parce que ça c'est c'est moins
connu une fois que vous avez enlevé le
les cuisses pour faire du conflit le
gésier les cœurs on mange les cœurs de
canards c'est aussi délicieux en
brochettes que enlever les magrets vous
laissez des aiguillettes et puis
évidemment toujours comme ta case de
poulet et des tas de sauce et on est on
est fait griller dans les fêtes de
village
c'est pas très courant mais on y arrive
et on appelle ça des deux demoiselles et
donc voilà c'est un mais délicieux et
évidemment ça se mange avec les doigts
mais mais voilà de participer à quelques
fêtes de villages avec des demoiselles
les fêtes de village c'est c'est sacré
chez nous et vous avez vous avez une
fête du village qui va se faire autour
de la fève un repas autour de la fève
assez sombre par exemple vous avez le
repas qui va se faire autour du cochon
le tucochon ami élan voilà c'est des
fêtes qui réunissent dans des villages
de de 500 habitants vous avez 500
personnes qui sont à table parce qu'on
vient de tous les villages peut-être
manger partager voilà c'est une terre
évidemment gastronomique mais aussi une
culture du partage de la convivialité
partage c'est c'est de pouvoir
effectivement être en famille autour
d'un bon repas oui mais c'est vraiment
aussi au-delà de la famille c'est
vraiment c'est repas sont des repas de
village moi ce que je trouve admirable
dans le Gers c'est cette capacité qu'on
tous les villageois nos citoyens à faire
la fête ensemble tout est prétexte pour
ses grandes tables et vous arrivez dans
des grandes tables de village ou vous
connaissez pas nécessairement beaucoup
de monde vous asseyez tout de suite il
se passe quelque chose avec les gens qui
sont autour de vous voilà donc il y a
cette belle tradition la même manière
que
une tradition aussi très importante dans
le Gers c'est que vous allez chercher
les produits
vous n'avez pas un seul endroit chez
tous vos produits ce serait pas marrant
ce serait trop simple donc vous allez en
tel ferme pour trouver tellement de
produits
chercher du veau et puis après vous
allez aller faire manger pour aller
chercher du confit des cuisses donc
voilà il y a aussi ce plaisir
une ferme c'est pas plus gros que ça
au marché évidemment ou dans les marchés
de produits régionaux mais voilà il y a
ce plaisir d'aller chercher parce que ça
complique un peu la vie d'aller chercher
foie gras on goûte et puis
c'est sympa comme moi je valide ce genre
de parcours comment vous le trouvez ce
magret très bien très bien
oui
il y a bien le gras sauf qu'il a bien
fait griller on le voit à peine il y a
bien le gras ça c'est parfait ça c'est
parfait alors je sens votre gourmand
genre les caisses de mais est-ce que
vous êtes aussi bon au fourneau vous
préférez laisser ça à autrui
ah je vais pas vous mentir je suis pas
un grand cuisinier
mes enfants le son je pars non mais je
ne suis pas un grand cuisinier
j'ai quelques plats parce que je peux
évidemment je participe ce pot-au-feu je
fais quand même
j'ai quelques spécialités que je fais
avec plaisir pour mes pour mes amis
là vous déconstruisez la légende du
terroir mais bon chez moi
je peux vous faire du foie gras poêlés
parce que vous pouvez
vous pouvez le évidemment le servir avec
des endives braisées à la Grèce de
canard avec des raisins secs avec des
filles donc vous
récupérez le jetez jamais morts
ce serait péché donc récupérer le grain
et vous faites et n'importe quel légume
qui peut paraître sans saveur à certains
dès que vous le faites revenir dans la
graisse de canard au doigt c'est
évidemment ça devient un changement et
vous aimez ce mélange un peu sucré salé
ce que vous nous parlez de figues vous
nous parlez là on a un peu d'orange ça
se mange souvent effectivement le canard
à l'orange c'est un grand classique
aussi je résiste pas je mange en même
temps je pense évidemment quand on est
gourmand on est gourmands le cacher et
alors il y a un restaurant à Paris qui
fait le fameux je l'ai jamais goûté le
canard au sang il va rouvrir c'est la
Tour d'Argent est-ce que vous aimez le
canard au sang vous qui est un
spécialiste du canard ou est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que
il y a très longtemps j'y suis allé
j'étais invité effectivement bon un
grand un grand symbole c'est un grand un
grand classique oui ou c'est très bon
j'adore le canard j'adore le canard sur
toutes ces formes et le cochon sur
toutes ces formes et le canard laqué
bon magret un bon confit produit simple
alors il faut le dire on a décoré un
petit peu cette table parce que vous
êtes venus avec quelques produits de
chez vous alors racontez-nous déjà là il
y a du foie gras oui alors
on a ce plaisir nous d'aller chercher
chez tel ou tel producteur
son son c'est produit donc je vous
amenais un filet garni et puis donc on
l'a étalé mais ça s'il vous faudra de de
chez Ferris donc ça c'est un foie
mi-cuit qui effectivement il faut
canard d'accord absolument canard il y a
très peu ça veut dire pour les
téléspectateurs qu'il a été cuit à 60
degrés il faut que à coeur il soit très
peu cuit enfin disons qu'il est un peu
rosé
alors
de préparer le foie gras j'imagine qu'on
en reparlera tout à l'heure
moi je le prépare quand je le fais au
sel donc oui et 24 heures un torchon et
du self évidemment mettre de l'Armagnac
on en parlera aussi un petit peu cette
recette
à peu près tout donc voilà ça c'est du
foie gras
chercher c'est ça chez d'autres d'autres
fournisseurs il y a la garbure que je
crois pas ouvrir que vous prendrez chez
vous c'est c'est la soupe populaire
gascogne-bernaise d'origine
il y a quoi dedans alors c'est la soupe
populaire donc je nos ancêtres y
mettaient ce qu'ils avaient si vous
voulez
en fait au départ au départ ils mettent
ce qu'ils avaient donc ils avaient un
peu de pommes de terre ils montent en
pomme de terre ils avaient un bout de
lard ils mettaient un bout de là
évidemment avec le temps la recette
c'est c'est enrichi et vous avez
maintenant
confie
Poirot céleri ail viande de canard chou
pomme de terre haricots carotte navet
lard de Porcel épices
un peu sophistiqué je suis pas sûr nos
ancêtres plonger des soupes aussi riff
ça c'est la maison Ramajo là vous avez
là on a un petit pâté campagnard un
petit pâté campagnard de de chez
clairefontage je crois du du jambonneau
de campagne
extrêmement attachant il agriculteurs
qui aiment leur métier et ce sont des
agriculteurs de petites tailles vous
n'êtes pas de gros industries
agroalimentaires et c'est à la fois un
tourisme on peut faire un tourisme
agricole de le notori isthme voilà et à
ce plaisir d'aller de ferme en ferme
faire ses courses ou visiter voir
comment ça marche voir comme ça comment
il fabrique le foie gras peut-être pour
mais alors vous vous aimez vraiment la
vie on peut pas être du Gers c'est ne
pas aimer la viande c'est j'ai
l'impression qu'à base de tout tout vos
repas sont à base de viande
quand on est député dans le Gers on a la
chance tout se termine par un tout
commence par un apéritif il y a pas une
assemblée générale qui se termine pas
par un apéritif etc donc il faut quand
même faire attention donc je fais
attention je dis pas qu'il faut manger
de la viande à tous les repas et je
crois que c'est plutôt bien qu'on mange
moins la viande de manière de manière
générale mais mieux de viande donc
il faut que nous ayons des produits de
meilleure qualité et dans les choix que
doit faire un certain nombre français
qui ont évidemment des revenus
quelquefois
limités je trouve bien qu'ils achète
peut-être on en parlera tout à l'heure
mais de meilleure qualité donc je crois
que ça n'est pas incompatible mais
effectivement je suis un pays de la
bonne chair du gras le gras c'est bon
le gras c'est le gras c'est la vie ma
maman et gros débat sur le foie gras
parce qu'il se trouve que mon ma
grand-mère est Alsacienne j'ai trois
grands-parents gascons et puis une qui
est Alsacienne qui est venue dire dans
le Gers pour suivre son mari et le foie
gras vient en Alsace en France on est
arrivé par l'Alsace alors il y a des
débats sans fin
on vous montrera sans fin pour savoir
quel est le meilleur foie gras et
comment on mange de ma faut regarder ce
qu'on met le grain est-ce qu'on le met
sur du pain toasté sur du pain d'épice
sur etc il y a un débat et même on dit
d'habitude de dire il y a trop de pain
donc si vous entendez
c'est toujours
ça suffit très bien alors vous nous avez
demandé pour accompagner ce magret des
légumes de saison et notamment des
asperges c'est une un légume que vous
appréciez particulièrement
des asperges j'adore ça mais il y en a
pas parce que il y a pas de production
d'asperges dans le dans le Gers ou en
tous les cas c'est marginal j'ai
peut-être dire une bêtise mais je je
n'en vois pas dans le Lot-et-Garonne
alors Lot-et-Garonne où il y a beaucoup
beaucoup plus de fruits et de et de des
légumes il y a évidemment des légumes
mais que sur ma recherche sont pas très
développés dans le dans le jardin la
pomme de terre
champignons vous aviez demandé à
l'église de saison c'est vrai que
l'asperge se marie très bien avec
absolument
à la saisonnalité des produits à acheter
effectivement au bon moment à la bonne
saison je crois que c'est une bonne
habitude qu'on a perdu c'est vrai qu'on
a tous été tentés par ces supermarchés
dans lesquels vous avez en toute saison
tout type de produits je veux dire c'est
quoi ce matin il faut tourner cette page
il faut tourner cette page là
collectivement est-ce qu'il faut
l'interdire je crois pas mais il faut
que chacun
serait responsabilise et soit conscient
de l'impact que ça sur le sur le sur le
climat il faut faire comme nous vos
parents manger des manger des légumes de
saison des fruits et des légumes de
saison alors pour accompagner en tout
cas ce magret vous nous avez demandé du
Tariquet Tariquet c'est un vin qu'on
trouve dans le Sud-Ouest assez largement
parce que c'est un très grand domaine
c'est dans la région de Gascogne
évidemment la couleur c'est un vin blanc
sec et il a une appellation IGP AOP et
les cépages du Tariquet c'est uni blanc
Colombard chenin sauvignon chardonnay et
gros mansin et là on est sur un
millésime 2021 parce qu'il faut plutôt
le boire dans dans l'année en général
donc ça ça fait partie de votre corps
je voudrais
rendre hommage aux viticulteurs pour
compter peut-être aussi une anecdote
personnelle j'habite la maison de mes
grands-parents quand j'étais gamin au
bout de la colline il y avait des vignes
bon et
mon grand-père a porté le raisin à la
coopérative et puis revenez de la
coopérative du vin bon et il y a pas
plus Chauvin pas plus gascon que mon
grand-père et non ça franchement on peut
pas le boire bon et ça c'était il y a 30
ou 40 ans et on a fait un progrès
absolument colossal on n'est pas les
seuls mais on a fait un progrès
absolument colossal il y a maintenant
des dizaines et dizaines d'appellations
dans dans le Gers de vin qui sont
absolument fabuleux à des petits prix
donc et le tariki est un peu le symbole
de ça c'était
mondialement mondialement connus ils ont
ils ont vraiment innové ils ont vraiment
pris des risques qui sont sur les terres
où on faisait de l'Armagnac
traditionnellement donc ils ont apporté
un certain nombre de cépages ils ont
fait vénification un peu un peu un peu
ils ont fait des des assemblages
particuliers ils ont bénéficié d'un
climat au mois d'août qui est un climat
très particulier parce qu'il fait plutôt
chaud la journée plutôt frais on est
près des Pyrénées donc plutôt frais donc
à ce moment un très important pour le
les arômes le fruité des des grappes
voilà et donc on a un produit des vins
qui font largement largement en dessous
de de 10 euros vous pouvez manger avec
des huîtres Arcachon que vous pouvez
manger que boire manger boire pardon en
Angleterre voilà c'est un gros succès et
c'est une vraie locomotive et les Côtes
de Gascogne mais parler du chirouler du
du pélo de des samons et aussi les les
les madirans avec Brumont donc arrêtez
sa famille grâce à qui a fait ça sur
quelques générations qui a réussi
vraiment à faire des Côtes de Gascogne
un vin
mondialement connu maintenant et voilà
on va arrêter si je me trompe Brig il me
semble que le jour vous avez déjà servi
un Tariquet mais il était complètement
différent oui c'était les premières
grives que vous devez connaître
absolument un petit peu plus moelleuse
là on est sur un vin blanc sec en fait
je pense que c'est classique et donc oui
mais attends il se décline mais l'autre
peut-être irait bien sur le foie gras
absolument mais donc le Gers c'est
devenu très en avance de phase où c'est
que maintenant il y a un basculement
très important la consommation du rouge
vers le blanc
au niveau mondial qui pose quelques
problèmes aux producteurs de rouge en
particulier nous on a la chance je crois
qu'on est peut-être le premier
département en production de vin blanc
et donc on bénéficie de ça donc pour
l'économie c'est aussi important de
parler un peu économie sur la commission
des finances comment vous la suis ravi
que cette que le blanc remplace le rouge
je suis incapable
il y a aussi du pêcherin qui est de de
caster de René caster qui est
viticulteur que j'ai que j'ai amené donc
ça c'est du côté Madiran m'a dit
probablement entendu parler Monsieur
Bruno là aussi qui est un grand
ambassadeur de ce vin donc là je vous
laisserai goûter il se marie très bien
un peu l'équivalent du jour au son pas
très éloigné et donc qui se marie très
bien avec le foie gras en particulier on
goûtera un peu plus tard alors on va
voir si vous êtes vraiment incollable
c'est le quiz
alors avec votre look de mousquetaires
vous devez connaître par cœur le grand
dictionnaire de la cuisine d'Alexandre
Dumas c'est vraiment un ouvrage de
référence qu'il faut de temps en temps
consulter je l'ai fait alors concernant
le canard donc elle allait être ses
canards quelle est la recette parmi les
quatre suivantes qui ne figure pas dans
le Grand Dictionnaire de la cuisine
d'Alexandre Dumas a le canard au verjus
B le canard à la choucroute c'est le
canard à l'orange le D canard aux navets
à la bourgeoise
pas facile alors il a écrit ça à la fin
de sa vie
1860 effectivement alors lui c'est un il
est pas du tout gascon mais évidemment
on assimile à
c'est vraiment générique parle de toute
la cuisine mais une fois que vous restez
des heures alors
le canard à la choucroute il est capable
de l'avoir fait mais je vais quand même
dire ça parce que j'avais vraiment
jamais entendu parler mais bien non
c'est le canard à l'orange qui ne figure
pas dans le Grand Dictionnaire
d'Alexandre Dumas à la recette des
canards alors Jean René Cazeneuve vous
qui avez travaillé chez Apple la marque
à la pomme êtes-vous un collable sur ce
fruit quels sont les usages en cuisine
de ces variétés de pommes alors a Fuji
est-ce que c'est pour la tarte est-ce
que c'est pour le boudin est-ce que ça
se fait en compote ou est-ce que ça se
mange cru
la Fushi
c'est un peu acide donc je mettrais avec
le boudin non pour le contraste alors
non ça se mange cru ça se mange cru
alors B bellechard la belle chart alors
qu'est-ce qui nous reste tarte boudin ou
compote
c'est un moment difficile voilà
je crois que je suis Apple il y avait
des stages de pommes donc moi je pensais
que j'étais très vieux vous savez j'ai
tourné la page de tout ça c'est tout ça
c'est vieux je veux dire la compote
bravo alors c'est la compote bravo c'est
Ariane donc Ariane est-ce que c'est
tarte ou boudin
là je vais mettre en
tarte bravo et donc reine des reinette
il nous reste le boudin voilà bon vous
étiez pas tout à fait incollable en
terme de pommes
le repas occupe une assez large place et
particulièrement en politique c'est
souvent là que ce nous les deals ou que
se fait la petite et la grande Histoire
et c'est la brève de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé je remets
Cazeneuve de réfléchir à une histoire
politique autour d'un repas est-ce qu'il
y a une petite anecdote qui vous est
revenue
alors on sait qu'on a un ancien premier
ministre Jean Castex qui est gersoit
d'origine donc qui a vécu ces 20
premières années dans le Gers c'est qui
on entend à son accent
partiellement fidèle évidemment ces
valeurs de convivialité à son terroir et
donc quand il a été premier ministre on
s'est vu assez rapidement il m'a dit il
va faire un déplacement dans le verre
super Monsieur le Premier Ministre
parfait etc etc bon et puis on travaille
comme d'habitude en contre avec les élus
vis d'une entreprise
hôpital enfin voilà il annonce l'hôpital
de Dodge et puis
assez rapidement une petite demande
personnelle
je voudrais dîner
chez chez mon ami
et et en fait il avait
il voulait profiter vous êtes conseiller
voyage ils sont absolument calibrés
chaque minute etc il a dit non là je
peux pas venir manger sans retrouver
cette ce c'est souvenir mon enfance il
allait chez cette amie et on a il est
allé jusqu'à détailler c'était vraiment
ça madeleine de Proust où il avait été
chez des parents de
d'un restaurant où c'est un particulier
c'est un particulier qui de fait j'ai
découvert après et ma suppléante
avec elle à l'école et il allait chez
ses parents et le très très souvent et
il lui a demandé il a dit voilà avec qui
je veux manger voilà je veux du magret
des pommes de terre à la graisse de
canard avec des cèpes à la graisse de
canard je vais la croustade en dessert
donc voilà il avait absolument imaginer
dans le détail pour retrouver ce plaisir
voilà clin d'oeil on a passé évidemment
dîner extrêmement sympa il y avait une
petite dizaine de personnes personnelles
évidemment hors protocole mais voilà
c'était il avait envie de revivre ça
c'était pour lui une parenthèse heureuse
en dans un jardin vous imaginez c'était
de allez on va rester dans le dans le
Gers et on va continuer à parler du foie
gras vous allez voir qu'il existe des
fois naturellement gras c'est le dessous
des plats
le gavage des canards et des oies pour
faire du foie gras et de plus en plus
contesté par les défenseurs du bien-être
animal certains producteurs élèvent des
oies qui s'auto gavent et dont le foie
devient naturellement gras peut-être la
poule aux oeufs d'or pour cet éleveur
située non loin de Colmar reportage
permittal Carniel Marion Devauchelle
gaver ou ne pas gaver telle est la
question en Alsace Marcel Metzler veut
faire évoluer le foie gras avec son
temps alors pour l'instant on prend en
banque du foie gras conventionnel et
nous sommes en train de mettre sur pied
la production de foie gras sans gavage
et nous en attendant les autorisations
alors pour l'instant on a fait des
validations du principe qui marche
effectivement on a fait des produits
mais que nous appelons pas foi gras et
ça c'est le futur de ce qu'on veut faire
le foie noir naturellement bien élevé
un déclic qu'il a eu en observant ses
oiseaux gavés en mangeant n'importe quoi
toute la journée
c'est celle qui montre servi à faire le
test ces voilà sont ici à l'état un peu
sauvage depuis plus de 10 ans mais on
s'aperçoit que dès qu'on leur donne et
combien pour leur donner à manger ou
dans le verger ou du pain ou du maïs
elles sont toujours là et tout à l'heure
si je venais avec du maïs elle mangerait
du maïs ce qui prouve que les oies
mangent tout le temps quoi c'est un
petit peu et donc on les observent une
production sans gavage le résultat des
fois moins gras et 400 grammes contre
600 pour les conventionnels avec tout de
même du goût et ça sans souffrance
animale
le but de l'appeler foie gras si nous
négociations en cours avec le ministère
et avec les instances administratives
parce que c'est le mot foie gras c'est
le mot patrimoine c'est le mot
gastronomie quoi effectivement froide ça
pourrait passer mais c'est parce qu'on
me nous on veut montrer qu'il est
possible de faire du foie gras d'une
façon tout naturelle mais pas possible
pour lui de donner ce nom une
proposition de loi a été déposée en 2021
pour ouvrir l'appellation foie gras foie
gras réalisé sans gavage elle n'a
toujours pas été débattue à l'Assemblée
[Musique]
on ne les gave pas naturellement elles
ont le foie qui est gras est-ce que pour
vous c'est du foie gras non ça n'est pas
du foie gras je respecte le travail de
cette agriculteur de ce producteur mais
il faut pas il faut pas confondre
d'abord il découvre que ce qu'on sait
depuis toujours c'est que un métabolisme
qui fait que les les
oiseaux migrateurs créent du grain stock
du Grand ils ont une capacité donc
c'est pas par hasard que les canards et
les oies stockent de même de la Grèce
donc c'est ce qui fait donc et donc des
fois on des fois gras mais on
on garde les
oies et les canards depuis l'Antiquité
les preuves aujourd'hui en Égypte quand
vous regardez et donc c'est arrivé avec
probablement la diaspora juive au
travers de l'Europe de l'Europe de l'est
d'ailleurs il y a encore des pays où qui
fabriquent du foie gras en Roumanie en
gris puis c'est arrivé par l'Alsace puis
après c'est arrivé dans le Sud-Ouest
mais très tardivement contrairement à ce
qu'on peut imaginer c'est pas créé et la
combinaison entre
ces canards qu'on gavent et l'arrivée du
maïs qui arrivait des États-Unis donc ça
on est au 19e siècle et là vous avez
évidemment une capacité à faire des fois
des fois magnifiques donc c'est vraiment
très différent est-ce que vous par
exemple à l'aveugle vous seriez
forcément reconnaître le vrai foie gras
qui est on GAV loi ou le canard et c'est
fois naturellement propose ce produit
aucun problème si vous voulez juste pas
l'appeler foie gras parce que il y aura
une confusion et un mensonge vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis des consommateurs donc vous ne
voteriez pas la loi pour la trouver un
autre nom mais bon on peut pas l'appeler
l'appeler foie gras si vous voulez il y
a des règles aujourd'hui le gavage est
très encadré en termes de bien-être
animal il faut aussi être précis vous
savez le gavage durant une dizaine de
jours maintenant on a réduit
considérablement cette période cette
dure une dizaine de jours ça dure
quelques secondes ils sont gavés 2 à 3
fois par jour et chaque gavage dure 2 à
3 secondes c'est fait c'est fait de
manière très très attention aime leur
bête
dans le gavage d'un canard ou du noix
non je crois pas que de souffrance
animale ce sont des bêtes qui sont aussi
élevés pour ça c'est toujours pareil si
vous voulez si vous si vous mangez pas
du magret et du foie gras vous n'avez
pas de canard donc il y a plus de canard
vous voyez ce que je veux dire donc il
faut faire attention à cette à cette
enchaînement
donc si vous voulez moi j'ai pas de
problème à ce qu'on crée de nouveau
produit il faut juste pas l'appeler foie
gras parce qu'il y a pas le même goût il
a pas la même taille il a pas la même
texture et donc ce serait ce serait
menti en consommateur mais vous n'êtes
pas prêt à accepter finalement même si
faire un tout petit peu moins bon ce
foie gras naturellement gras comme bien
l'expliquer Brigitte pour se débarrasser
de cette question un peu embarrassante
du bien-être animal se dit foutons la
paix aux oies certes on aura un foie
gras un peu moins bon mais tout le monde
est content non vous voulez passer non
alors il est pratiquement deux fois plus
petit donc il coûte 3 fois plus cher
donc retombe sur un produit élitique oui
c'est que les oies donc on retombe sur
un extrêmement élitiste donc le le déjà
un produit élitiste le foie gras quand
même pas tant que ça
produit le fait c'est un produit de fête
évidemment une petite anecdote tu avais
une année j'avais ramené du du foie gras
pour m'attacher parlementaire me dire
super merci est-ce que je peux le garder
jusqu'à Noël pourquoi tu veux
pas non plus
donc c'est à dire vous entendez bien
quand même cette petite musique autour
de du gavage des oies et des canards qui
provoquent de la souffrance animale
beaucoup d'associations qui luttent
contre ça vous Croy ez pas que c'est un
peu dans le sens de l'histoire et qu'on
va y venir il y a plusieurs pays qui ont
interdit aussi le foie gras si on décide
de plus manger d'escargots d'huître on
peut effectivement mais il faut accepter
cette idée là quand même que ce sont des
élevages spécifiques et qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez une prise de conscience de
tous les agriculteurs de toute la chaîne
d'ailleurs de manière générale il y a
pas de la maltraitance sur les huiles
l'impact sur sur CB venez dans le gère
je vous invite à venir vous allez voir
les canards qui pendant trois mois plus
de trois mois vivent dehors et se régale
et donc effectivement il y a dix jours
pendant lesquels ils vont être gavés qui
est un processus une fois de plus qui
existe ils sont prêts ils sont prêts
pour ça et on minimise l'impact pour un
produit délicieux donc c'est notre
patrimoine attention de pas traditions
j'ai pas de problème mais qui veulent
pas l'interdire aux autres c'est
toujours pareil c'est quand même en est
là sur une vision de l'écologie du
bien-être animal despotique ceux qui
veulent pas en manger ils en mangent pas
ne nous embêtez pas quand on fait quand
on cherche de la convivialité
effectivement on boit on mange et c'est
grand et on adore ça est-ce qu'on est
sûr que c'est bête ne souffre pas vous
dites à dire quelques secondes c'est
extrêmement rapide est-ce qu'on est sûr
finalement que que la bête n'est pas en
souffrance à ce moment là
je pense que la souffrance est minimale
en tout cas on fait tout pour qu'elle
soit absolument minimale et une vache et
quand vous allez l'abattoir est
nécessairement il y a une souffrance
pressentiment on va pas arrêter de
manger non plus sous prétexte que il y a
potentiellement une souffrance notre
responsabilité c'est peut-être de moins
manger ce ce la viande on a dit on en a
parlé tout à l'heure mais de mieux de
viande et c'est aussi de travailler sur
que pour cette souffrance animale entre
guillemets soit minimale et soit en tous
les cas la plus réglementée possible et
la plus suivie possible mais vous savez
que vos propos là que vous êtes en train
de dire effectivement qu'ils sont
presque anodin dire le canard souffrant
pas tellement ça va ça prend des
proportions ça enflamme les esprits sur
les réseaux sociaux des gens ne
supportent plus aujourd'hui d'entendre
dire un homme politique un canard ne
souffre pas lorsqu'il est gavé chacun
prend ses responsables mais politique
j'ai l'habitude de prendre mes
responsabilités et donc si vous voulez
oui je vous dis vous le déplorez qu'on
puisse plus dire des choses comme ça
on peut tout supprimer on peut manger
que des que des que du quinoa si vous
aimez perdre quelque chose bon donc je
crois que c'est corrida vous êtes un
ardent défenseur de la corrida c'est que
c'est comme la corrida si vous voulez
bon si vous avez pas effectivement il y
a 800 euros
chaque année qui sont battus dans les
arènes mais si vous n'avez pas de
corrida et vous avez pas de taureau
demande alors leur avis est-ce qu'ils
veulent vivre quatre ans pénard et puis
avoir une fin difficile ou est-ce qu'ils
veulent pas vivre du tout j'en sais rien
mais bon donc
la traduction c'est Notre culture c'est
notre territoire les gens sont très
attachés sont très attachés à ça que les
habitudes évoluent tant mieux
lissons ses habitudes écoutons nos
jeunes qui nous disent ben non on mange
trop de gens non il faut pas faire ceci
non faut arrêter mais pourquoi pas mais
moi je revendique je revendique cette
convivialité et un virage trop brutal
par rapport à ces belles traditions on
vient dans le Gers pour le foie gras
enlevez foie gras
ça fait c'est vraiment les éleveurs du
Gers ils s'interrogent pas eux-mêmes sur
leur pratique sur sur ces tendances en 6
fois gras si vous leur dites qu'on peut
avoir le même produit sans gainage et
sans tuer le canard ils vont tout de
suite
c'est pas pareil voilà non évidemment ça
n'existe pas c'est beaucoup plus cher
c'est beaucoup plus petit ça pas le même
goût ensemble c'est une sorte de Canada
Dry si vous voulez donc mais non mais
vous avez vous posez une question
absolument fondamentale surtout ces
sujets là tous les agriculteurs que je
rencontre sont les premiers à défendre
la condition animale ce sont les preuves
ils vivent avec ces bêtes et ce sont pas
des bourreaux comme je voudrais vous
faire croire certains ils aiment leur
bête et vivent avec ses bêtes il les
protège ils font tout je peux vous dire
jusqu'au dernier moment jusqu'à ce
moment du gavage pour que l'animal ne
souffre pas en tous les cas le moins le
moins possible
alors on va parler maintenant d'un tout
autre sujet et c'est l'inflation
alimentaire qui a atteint une hausse
moyenne de 16% le mois dernier sur un an
alors difficile de faire face pour les
Français on en parle et on met les pieds
dans le plat
oui Brigitte avec cette inflation à les
étiquettes des produits alimentaires
flambes cela bouleverse nos habitudes de
consommation une grande partie des
Français achètent moins de viande et ce
rubrent plutôt sur les marques de
distribution dans les grandes surfaces
reportage de Marion Becker et d'André
Lafont dans une grande surface du Loiret
près d'Orléans
ça va
depuis un an à cause de l'inflation il a
vu les habitudes de ses clients évoluer
avec lui nous allons découvrir les
rayons les plus impactés donc là je vous
emmène au rayon boucherie traditionnel
vous avez la boucherie trad avec le
vendeur et juste à côté aussi vous avez
la même chose la même offre en frais
emballé qui est emballé par nos bouchers
donc vous avez les produits et ce qu'on
constate
depuis le contexte inflationniste c'est
que le client préfère rechercher un
produit en ayant directement son info du
prix
au moins il a déjà son budget en tête il
s'est il s'est tout de suite voilà si
j'en veux pour moins de 20 euros plus de
20 euros et il maîtrise tout de suite
son pouvoir d'achat en cette veille de
Pâques le traditionnel gigot est mise à
l'honneur par rapport à il y a deux ans
en effet on était à moins de 8 euros le
kilo donc là aujourd'hui vous voyez on a
déjà passé la barre des 9 euros des 9
euros le kilo sur donc là sur du
Nouvelle-Zélande après en face on a le
français
qui lui a aujourd'hui arrive à un prix
au kilo à près de 25 euros le kilo pour
le moment on est sur un petit peu moins
en vente par rapport à pas que l'année
dernière
[Musique]
il y a des choses qu'on achète plus oui
ça c'est vrai
le gigot là 21 euros ça fait cher ça on
le prend parce qu'il y a nos enfants
c'est un peu plus pour pas parce que
sinon jamais on achète ça c'est pour pas
que pour faire quelque chose on regarde
d'abord auprès du kilo voilà pour eux la
viande est devenue un produit de luxe
l'année dernière en France elle est
ventes de viande ont chuté de 7%. le
poisson lui de 13% alors pour tenir leur
budget ses retraités font la chasse aux
promotions comme 42% des Français des
gâteaux on prend la tête moins cher
faut compter faut compter pour pour
te donner à nos besoins on essaye de
prendre ce qui est magasin vous voyez
les clients remplacent les marques
devenues trop chères par les marques
distributeurs concrètement là quand on
arrive devant le rayon des pattes là
aujourd'hui c'est la marque u ce pavé là
où vous avez que du produit U et c'est
lui qui est le rayon qui est le plus
attaqué vous avez le plus de rupture ce
que les clients regardent aussi c'est
les produits nous qui sont aussi avec
des avantages avec notre carte de
fidélité
Céline y est très attentive elle est
mère de deux enfants elle n'achète de la
marque qu'en promotion il y avait la
Pom'Potes qui était en promotion je
viens de comparer avec Super U au final
la pompote est quand même moins chère
avec les trois lots voilà
l'année dernière cette française sur dix
affirme avoir déjà renoncé à faire
certaines de leurs courses à cause de
l'inflation
il aurait pu être tourné à Auch vous
arpentez votre circonscription des
Français qui comptent quand ils font
leurs courses vous en croisez de plus en
plus oui je suis allé aussi cette
semaine voire tes responsables de
supermarché pour évidemment voir avec
eux aussi l'ampleur que ça avait donc
c'est c'est
indubitable il y a aujourd'hui une
pression sur une inflation qui est
particulièrement forte sur
l'alimentation et qui pénalise nos
concitoyens qui les emmène à faire un
certain nombre de changement d'habitude
de changement de comportement qui ont
été très bien illustrés une étude Ifop
disait que 42% des Français allaient
jusqu'à se priver d'un repas en France
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle c'est ça
vous choque c'est on a l'impression que
attention de donc non bien sûr c'est
pour ça qu'on a quand même mais en
sortant de dispositif mais pas là faut
parler de la politique le gouvernement
mais on a quand même l'inflation la plus
maîtrisée de tout l'ensemble des pays
d'Europe donc c'est important et c'est
vrai que les Français aujourd'hui alors
c'est pas tellement que leur budget
alimentation a baissé c'est le reste ils
ont fait ils ont fait des arbitrages sur
les autres types de dépenses pour
maintenir il reste le même et avec ça
même chose ils n'achètent pas les mêmes
choses donc ils vont ils vont vous allez
produire
qui sont plus des produits de marque
donc des produits de supermarché vers
effectivement des produits plus simples
vers des des pattes alimentaires vers un
centre de de produits de ce type là à
budget à peu près
identique pour justement être capable
d'encaisser mais on a été mal habitué on
a on a bénéficié pendant très longtemps
d'une alimentation pas chère qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il y a aussi un
rééquilibrage au-delà de la guerre en
Israël alors effectivement au-delà de la
gare Ukraine il y a une volonté
vous savez la loi egalim 1 la loi egalim
2 pense aussi très important pour la
souveraineté de notre pays ça commence à
commence par l'alimentation et
aujourd'hui quand on regarde les
chiffres on est quand même très étonnés
de voir que nos exportations ont
fortement chuté on importe la moitié des
poulets enfin il y a quand même des
choses qui qui doivent aujourd'hui nous
alerter sur notre capacité à soutenir
nos agriculteurs donc on a voté doit
pour que nos agriculteurs vivent
correctement de leur de leurs produits
donc ça ça me paraît sans être c'est pas
ça se répercute un peu ça doit aussi les
négociations que nous avons eu avec les
grandes enseignes de distribution
doivent permettre aussi que ce sont
aussi aux enseignes de mettre une
pression sur leur marge à elle de faire
attention sur ce calcul c'est toujours
nous qui payons et c'est aux industriels
de faire des efforts aussi il y a une
bataille vous le savez aujourd'hui ça
porte quelques fruits reconnaissent
l'ancienne président de la fin
le reconnaissent aussi voilà ces lois
ont eu un effet positif sur le revenu
des agriculteurs c'est extrêmement
important mais c'est pas ça qui explique
aujourd'hui évidemment l'inflation très
forte et attention de pas de pas
mélanger pas faire porter la
responsabilité sur nos pauvres
agriculteurs donc il y a aujourd'hui une
inflation qui était historiquement une
inflation sur l'énergie et l'inflation
importée mais qui évidemment en train de
se diffuser sur l'ensemble des produits
industriels bien ils utilisent de
l'énergie donc il répercute on voit
qu'ils entreprises pendant la grande
majorité d'entre elles répercutent
répercute et prix donc il faut continuer
à soutenir nos concitoyens sur
parce qu'il y a eu le panier
anti-inflation qui qui est déjà en
vigueur on a l'impression que finalement
ça réduit pas tellement la facture du
caddie quand même
l'inflation était à peu près contenue au
mois de au mois de mars un chiffre qu'on
a été légèrement en baisse alors je sais
pas si on est encore sur l'alimentation
pas trop sur l'alimentation mais il y a
pas de raison qualimentation ne suit pas
les prix de gros baisse maintenant sur
l'alimentation donc il va falloir
évidemment un peu de temps donc ça
serait percute sur les produits de
détail on a quand même des signes
encourageant dans de baisse des produits
alimentaires donc oui c'est un moment
difficile peut-être qu'il va falloir on
a réflexion sur le chèque alimentaire il
faut le faire ce chèque alimentation
parce qu'on monte tergivers et puis je
crois qu'il faut le faire il y a des
sujets techniques il faut être capable
de faire en sorte qu'ils soutiennent
l'alimentation de qualité on en a parlé
tout à l'heure donc oui il faut
continuer à travailler il faut vraiment
aider nos concitoyens qui sont
aujourd'hui les plus impactés par cette
pas par cette inflation alors constant
je vois bien dans ce reportage les
Français achètent moins de viande alors
sans être cynique moins de viande pour
des raisons économiques parce que c'est
cher on voit bien le gigot qui augmente
sans être cynique est-ce que c'est
finalement pas un bien pour un mal
puisqu'on nous dit qu'il faut consommer
et apprendre à consommer moins de viande
et parallèlement il y a des sondages qui
disent que les Français trouvent que
l'état des accompagne pas assez dans
cette volonté de manger moins de viande
donc est-ce que finalement l'économie va
pas faire du bien à la planète en
obligeant les gens à manger moins de
viande
je fais pas partie de ceux qui pensent
que l'État doit tout faire et en
particulier expliquer à chacun de nos
concitoyens combien ils doivent manger
de viande non je crois pas je pense que
si imaginez un ministre en train de dire
bon maintenant les Français vont manger
tel quantité de viande par mois
évidemment non mais je voudrais un peu
de pédagogie autour de ça pas forcément
des solutions
il y a une sensibilisation d'ailleurs il
y a un changement de comportement donc
un changement de comportement moi je
crois qu'il faut
il faut être flexible à rien c'est à
dire effectivement peut-être manger
moins de viande pour être capable de
manger de la viande de qualité la viande
qui vient de nous producteurs dont on
connaît l'origine je trouve qu'on a
aussi progressé sur l'affichage des
produits maintenant qu'on est dans un
restaurant où on est on doit vous dire
d'où vient cette vient cette viande donc
j'encourage
nos concitoyens à exiger des produits
français dans une boucherie aujourd'hui
vous savez quand je vais en boucherie du
Gers quand j'ai chez la brique là je
sais exactement d'où vient mon agneau à
moi de prendre la responsabilité donc
moi je suis aussi pour chacun se prenne
la main sur cette consommation de viande
donc comment j'ai un peu moins de viande
effectivement il y a un effet bénéfique
mais ne comptez pas sur moi pour
condamner si vous voulez ce qui ce qui
mange de la viande on en a besoin
la viande a participé quand même
grandement à ce que l'Homo sapiens est
devenu s'il n'est pas mangé je peux dire
qu'on en serait pas là on fait de la
viande une vitraux la viande de synthèse
qu'est-ce que vous pensez vous de cette
de ces steaks végétaux qu'on n'aime pas
vraiment le droit d'appeler steak non
plus même chose si vous voulez pourquoi
pas
appeler pastèque c'est comme le foie
gras vous pouvez faire tous les produits
que vous voulez mais ne crée pas de
confusion vis-à-vis du de nos
concitoyens donc ne les appelons pas
steak on les appelle je crois qu'ils ont
gagné
du consommateur donc il y a des mots qui
ont un sens à un steak c'est un steak si
vous voulez un steak une viande et là
pour l'un d'esprit de tout le monde
chacun sait
d'où ça vient et comment c'est fait ou à
peu près bon donc si c'est fait dans une
usine chimique
en Inde si vous voulez il faut juste
prévu prévoir prévenir qu'on sache un
peu qu'on
certains veulent manger ça pourquoi pas
en tous les cas qui est pas de confusion
et une fois de plus rien ne vaut une
bonne vente
au barbecue comme dirait
allez on laisse de côté la viande et on
passe au dessert c'est le péché mignon
et le dessert du Gers brigitte c'est une
croustade du mot crosstada qui signifie
en occitan et en catalan croûte alors je
vous rassure Brigitte on va pas manger
une croûte non monsieur jean-luccassonne
est plus aimable que ça il nous offre
une croustade alors c'est d'abord une
pâte brisée feuilleté garni lorsqu'elle
est servi en dessert de toutes sortes de
bonnes choses ça peut être des fruits
cuits des fruits crus trempés dans
l'alcool de la confiture et devant nous
nous avons droit à une belle croustade
de pommes avec une petite pâte
feuilletée c'est votre croustade
préférée celle-ci à la pomme elle peut
se manger froide tienne ou chaude je
crois
c'est toujours bon oui vous voulez
goûter ou pas encore j'attends j'attends
vous donniez le premier coup d'épée
on vous remercions encore pour votre
invitation mais
ce week-end en réfléchissant un peu à
ces sujets là je me souvenais quand
j'étais gamin que les repas se terminent
les repas de famille le dimanche
se terminer avec l'arrivée du Tour de
France oui c'est un souvenir de gamin
bon
[Musique]
et découper et cuite sur le sur la Costa
évidemment ça se goûte tellement qu'un
tout petit truc pas grave dArmagnac
ça on a bien compris mais moi je la
trouve honnêtement
chercher dans un restaurant du 14e
arrondissement elle est très très bonne
elle est très très bonne hein parce que
là la pâte est feuilletée c'est une très
bonne croustade hein
ça m'a l'air très compliqué
un vrai savoir-faire qui se transmet au
sein des familles c'est magnifique donc
les boulangers
salés au foie gras c'est vrai ou pas
ça m'étonnerait pas forcément
en fait la croustade c'est un terme
générique qui désigne toutes sortes de
de absolument on peut y mettre
différentes formes de crousta dans le en
Ariège pas tout à fait la même forme de
croustade donc il y a différentes formes
de ça c'est la croustade je reçois dès
que cette pâte fine qui normalement fait
aussi un petit peu
sucré je la connais que sucré
alors on se termine toujours cette
émission en musique vous avez choisi
celle-ci on l'écoute et vous ne dites
pourquoi
[Musique]
alors
Jean-Pierre n'a pas reconnu moi non plus
qu'est-ce que c'est
alors c'est un champ traditionnel
dont on dit qu'il a été écrit par Gaston
Fébus
donc au 14e siècle est une qui est une
chanson
d'amour Gaston Fébus son utilité pas
très fidèle
et donc sa femme était repartie de
l'autre côté des Pyrénées et et voilà
c'est une chanson d'amour et ils ont à
ce que des Pyrénées descendent ce que
des plaines se relèvent de manière à ce
qu'ils puissent voir et envoyer ce champ
à son à son amour donc c'est la foi un
chant d'amour Jean qui qui est qui est
un hommage aux Pyrénées vous savez dans
le GR dans tout ce sud-ouest quand il
fait beau vous avez ces Pyrénées
magnifiques qui domine on les voit on
les voit d'Oches on les voit on est à
100 km à vol d'oiseau mais c'est
Pyrénées sont magnifiques donc voilà ça
c'est le champ traditionnel
qui peut terminer des repas qui peut
terminer une corrida qui peut terminer
des fêtes de village voilà c'est
vraiment le centre traditionnel
le chant d'amour quand on n'a pas les
bandes
quand les bandas se sont pas là on
chante c'est canto qui canto et et voilà
merci Jean-Marie
ce repas avec nous merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivis rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour un nouvel nouveau numéro
de politique à table sur LCP
[Musique]